for someone's a bit brand loyalty for
someone's about aspiration that marketed
in advertising different ways but let me
try and answer it as I can a technical
question a little bit more as a
technical question so some of this comes
down to the ways in which we think about
computer systems so generally if you
think about that it this way you have
what we would call the hardware then on
top of this we have a special set of
programs called the operating system and
on top of the operating system you will
have what's called applications yeah now
all of those also have what we brought
this speaking is a one doing system so
this is the ways in which they present
themselves to you this would be you you
would interact with a window say and you
that when do we interact with or what
process an application say that what
process an application would ask that
the underlying operating system to do
certain things like open a file and that
opening a file would make sense things
happen on the hardware so there's quite
a long history of different operating
systems from the very first inception
you would have different operating
systems which would run in different
manufacturers equipment so IBM would
have one anywhere would have another ICL
would have another and all of those
different systems would each have their
own operating systems so the BBC micro
had one the Commodore 64 had another and
all of those would come and go so they'd
be closely kind of tied to the hardware
historically what's happened is that
also each of those manufactures would
offer a different way of presenting the
computer so they have definite Wendling
systems so originally they would send it
to be command-line you taper to a line
and something that happened Macs and PCs
has been two of the main competitors at
one point through the nearly 80s
the big deference that people would
speak about would be the Wendling system
difference one was graphical 100 desktop
metaphor the other then with the advent
of that sort of facility on Windows
machines that deference less clear so a
Windows 8 machine and that mark intosh
interface uses icons may strides and
summaries but you still will have a
religious separation between people
available as each to each see that on a
slightly different ways so today I think
the real difference between them is that
Apple still own and build the hardware
that they put their operating system on
so they exist both as a software company
and a hardware company and it's only
recently that Microsoft have even
attempted to do that again
so the Microsoft Surface is the first
time Microsoft has sought to do this why
is that important well it's important
because what the operating system has to
do is translate the applications needs
and to things for the computer the
hardware to do and if you've built that
hardware you know how that hardware
works you can optimize in particular
ways if you do it then you can't
necessarily do that quite as smoothly
and quite as sufficiently so detecting
things happening in the hardware is more
difficult if you haven't built it
because you're relying and other people
building things so that's why and the
operating systems and Macintosh's can
actually make presumptions about the
hardware and its use and their for build
and optimize and can test that so
they've actually tasted their systems
with the actual hardware that they run
on Microsoft have a different
orientation their operating systems
installed in many manufacturers hardware
and so they can't really test that on
every single possible machine so that
means they're not is optimal at that
point or smooth at that point and the
run
line on what's called device drivers
being specifically installed for each
device so that we translate the
operating system commands to the
specifics of that hardware that's why
often you see when you're using a PC and
machine or Microsoft machine you will
see I need to reinstall and update and
change different drivers mostly those
are invisible in the Macintosh because
they're pretty much owned by Apple and
installed by Apple and updated by Apple
the plus side of this is it feels Nason
and more official the downside of this
is you've only got one machine that runs
on and therefore you've got a concealed
unit which means that mark intosh
machines are often accused of being more
expensive because on a Windows and when
does types the races you can run it on a
range of hardware from high to low end
and you can optimize the place of the
hardware down by running on that whereas
you don't have that range of hardware
and quite the same way I've used
Macintoshes and Microsoft as the kind of
classic divisions that people use but if
you actually go through the range of
others the separation down into
different systems also applies so in
terms of Lennox Lennox routes are from
original open-source UNIX people have
taken the converging UNIX platform and
ported that made it work honor honor on
a PC environments and sets of pcs
environment and so that operating system
is capable of running across a wide
range of hardware and also there is a
number of when doing systems that itself
supports now the advantage with Lennox
environments as Linux environments are
open and so no corporation or company
owns them quite the same way they're
open source they're modifiable by people
when people can moderate moderate them
and use them so it's championed is one
of the and classic and a champion one of
the one of the biggest forces for
keeping the internet and computer
systems open and accessible to all
floating-point looks at 1/10 plus 2/10
one who've just typed in naught point 1
plus not point to in decimal and it says
that 1/10 plus 2/10 does not quite equal
3/10 because to its mind 1 by it doesn't